which of the triangles triangle def
triangle ghi and triangle jkl are
similar to triangle abc and we have this
triangle abc they've given us or they've
just marked one of the angles and then
they've given the lengths of the two
sides on either side of that angle and
you might remember from geometry class
you can prove that two triangles are
similar is if you can show well they
have they have they have corresponding
congruent angles so let's say we're
trying to compare this triangle to this
triangle triangle j
j k l to triangle a
to triangle a b c
so if you can show that they have two
corresponding angles that are congruent
to each other and that the sides the
sides on either side the ratio between
the sides on either side of that of that
angle are the same then you're going to
be dealing with a similar triangle so
for example
if we say that this angle corresponds to
this angle they've already marked it to
say that they're congruent so that's a
pretty good starting point and if we
could show that the ratio
between
this side
and this side
side kl is the same as the ratio between
b a
and k j
then we can say that these two are
similar triangles now you might be
thinking well how did i how did i decide
to compare bc to kl and ba to kj well
either both of these are are the two
sides that essentially make up this
angle and bc is the shorter of the two
these are the two sides that make up
this angle two that are there both of
these are the i guess you could say
they're they're segments of the rays
they're parts of the rays that make up
this angle if you were to kind of
continue forever
if you were to continue forever and the
blue one is the shorter one so that's
the best candidate for being cor for kl
is the best course the best candidate
that to correspond to bc
well in order to do this we're gonna
have to figure out the lengths of the
sides we're going to do it for all of
these triangles right over here and they
don't give us the lengths but this thing
is sitting on a coordinate plane
now you could use the distance formula
but i like to just cut the chase the
distance formula is based on the
pythagorean theorem and they've drawn a
grid right over here for us so we could
just set up some right triangles to
figure out we can make each of these
sides essentially the hypotenuse of
right triangles
so
to figure out
to figure out the length of kj we could
set up this right triangle right over
here this height is three
this length right over here we could
count it it's one two three four five
six seven eight nine units wide
if we wanted to if they if we couldn't
count like that we could say look we're
going from x equals negative 6 to x
equals 3 3 minus negative 6 is equal to
9. let me make that clear that's
essentially where the distance formula
comes from 3 minus negative 6. you're
finding the change your change in x and
you're going to square it and then you
have your change in y you're going to
square it and that's going to be equal
to this hypotenuse squared
so let's think about
so
this is going to be equal to the square
root
i'm just using the pythagorean theorem
here so i'll just i'll just call it so k
let me just write it out so you don't
think i'm doing some type of voodoo
so three squared plus let me do a little
higher because i have a feeling i'm
going to use a lot of real estate three
squared
plus 9 squared is equal to the length of
kj
the length of kj squared
3 squared is 27 sorry not 27 3 squared
is 9
9 9 squared is 81 and then that's going
to be equal to the length of kj squared
or we get kj
squared is equal to
which is the same thing as 9 times 10
and so kj
is going to be it's the square root of
this so the square root of that is going
to be square root of 9 times 10 is equal
to the square root of 9
times the square root of 10 which is
equal to 3 square roots of 10. so it's
actually the exact same length as ba
now let's do the same thing for kl
for kl we could set up another right
triangle right over here
so its height is three and its width is
three this is three and three right over
here so we could write three squared
plus three
squared is equal to the length of kl
squared this right over here is 18
is equal to kl squared and if you take
the square root of both sides
18 is of course 9 times 2 so this right
over here this would square root of 8
this is the square root of 18 is equal
to
kl
square root of 18 is the same thing the
square root of 9 times 2 that's just 3
square roots of 2. this is equal to 3
square roots of 2.
so this is 3
square roots of 2. this is
square roots of 10. this angle is
congruent this angle is congruent to
this angle right over here so not only
are not only are abc and jkl not only
are they similar but these are actually
congruent triangles these are congruent
triangles right over here but they're
definitely all congruent triangles are
going to be similar so this one this one
is definitely similar jkl is similar to
abc
now let's figure out all of these
lengths up here
well you have let's see this is
one and one so you could say 1 squared
plus 1 squared is equal to
e f squared
is equal to the length of segment ef
squared or you could say ef
ef is equal to let's see this is 2 so
this is going to be the square root
of 2.
so actually i should have done that in
that blue color because this will be the
shorter we want this to be the shorter
side on the on if we're comparing the
two sides on either side of that angle
and now let's look at ed
now let's look at ed
so once again we can set up a right
triangle that is one wide and three tall
and so we could say
one squared 1 squared
plus 3 squared is equal to
e the length of e d squared see 1
squared plus 3 squared this is going to
be 10 so we get e d
is equal to the square root of 10.
now is the ratio between b c and e f the
same as the ratio between b a
and e d
so let's write this down so
square root of 3 i said 3 square roots
of 2 over square root of 2 is equal to
3. so the ratio between these two blue
sides between bc and ef is 3 the ratio
between these two orange sides is 3
square roots of 10
over square root of 10
3 square roots of 10
over
square root of 10 which is also 3.
so the ratio between these two
corresponding sides are the same the
angle in between is congruent so these
two triangles are also similar so efd or
def is also similar to abc so we have
one more to think about
so h i is a candidate to be
corresponding to bc what's its length
let's see this is a right triangle
that's width to height two so we could
write two squared plus 2 squared
is equal to the length of
h i squared this is 4 this is 4 so 8 is
equal to
is equal to
the length of h i
squared
and then we can take the square root of
both sides so the square root of 8 is
equal to the length of h i
or we could say the length of high or
the length of h i is equal to let's see
this is 4 times 2 so square root of 4
times square root of 2 is 2 square roots
of 2. so this is 2 square roots of 2 and
then the candidate for to be
corresponding to a b is hg it's the
longer of the of the two sides on either
side of this angle
so hg
we can set up a right triangle
hg we could set up a right triangle that
looks like
this
it's two wide and one two three four
five 6 high
so we can write let me scroll over to
the right a little bit we can write that
2 squared plus 6 squared is equal to the
length of h
g
squared
so let's see this is 4 plus 36 is equal
to the length of hg
squared or we get that hg
is equal to the square root of 40.
square root of 40 let's see how can we
simplify that that's that's that's the
same thing as the square root of 4 times
which is 2 times the square root of 10.
so h
g
is equal to 2
times the square root of 10. now let's
compare the ratios the ratio between b c
and h i is going to be 3 square roots of
3 square roots of 2
over 2 square roots of 2
over 2 square roots of 2 which is
3 halves
and the ratio between
a ba
which is 3 let me do that in that orange
color
which is 3 square roots of 10.
3 square roots of 10
and
h g which is 2 square roots of 10
is also
3 halves so all of these triangles are
not only are they similar to abc but
they're actually all similar
to each other